من جانبه قلم حمد الحسن ولد لباس مدير
وديوان الاتحاد الافريقي قال للجزيره ان
اجتماع الاليه الموسعه التي عقدت في اديس
ابابا اتفق على خريطه طريق جديده لحل
الازمه السودانيه
وتشدد هذه الاليه الموسعه على منع التدخل
الخارجي في الشؤون السودانيه
وتنسيق الاجراءات الدوليه ومنع اي مبادرات
تقلل من العمل المشترك
وتتضمن خارطه الطريق الافريقيه استئناف
العمليه السياسيه لاستكمال الانتقال
السياسي الذي توقف بسبب الصراع
هذا الاجتماع وافق على خارطه الطريق
الافريقيه التي اساسها العمل وسائل مختلفه
من اجل وقف اطلاق النار باسرع ما يكون
واذا وبالتالي تاييد مسار جده بين الذي
تشرف عليه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والسعوديه والذي ندمنه
وثانيا ان
يقام بعمل واسع ومتشعب لكل وكالاتي الغذاء
لاغاده الانسانيه من اجل ان تصل المساعدات
والاغاثه للسكان في مختلف مناطق السودان